حي على الفلاح
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
لا
اله الا الله
[Silence]
سبحان
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
ان الحمد لله
نحمده ونستعينه ونستغفره
ونعوذ بالله من شرور انفسنا وسيئات
اعمالنا
من يهده الله فلا مضل له
ومن يضلل فلا هادي له
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله حق تقاته
ولا تموتن الا وانتم مسلمون
يا ايها الناس
اتقوا ربكم
الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده
وخلق منها زوجها
وبث منهما رجالا كثيرا ونساء
واتقوا الله الذي تساءلون به والارحام
ان الله كان عليكم رقيبا
يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله وقولوا
قولا سديدا يصلح لكم اعمالكم ويغفر لكم
ذنوبكم
ومن يطع الله ورسوله فقد فاز فوزا عظيما
اما بعد فان اصدق الحديث كتاب الله
وخير الهدي هدي محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وشر الامور محدثاتها
وكل محدثه بدعه وكل بدعه ضلاله وكل ضلاله
في النار
اما بعد
فيقول الله تعالى في كتابه الكريم
والعصر
ان الانسان لفي خسر
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا بالصبر
وقد اخرج الحافظ الامام الامام ابو عيسى
الترمذي
رحمه الله تعالى في جامعه باسناده
عن ابي هريره رضي الله عنه
قال قال رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
الدنيا ملعونه
ملعون ما فيها الا ذكر الله وما والاه
وعالما ومتعلما
الدن الدنيا ملعونه
هنا المقصود اللعن اللغوي
فان اللعن في لغه العرب هو الابعاد
الشيء الحالك البعيد
والله عز وجل يقول في كتابه
كل من عليها فان ويبقى وجه وجه ربك ذو
الجلال والاكرام
والله عز وجل يقول
كل شيء هالك الا وجهه
وهذا معنى الدنيا ملعونه
واللعن قد يطلق ويراد به المعنى الشرعي
واللعن في الشريعه
الشيء
الذي قد ابعد عن رحمه الله
ولكن في اللغه
المقصود بالملعون
الدنيا ملعونه
ملعون ما فيها اي الدنيا هالكه بعيده عن
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اي الى الزوال
كل من عليها فان كل شيء هالك الا وجهه الا
ذكر الله وما ولاه
يعني ذكر الله
وما كان من ذكر الله
العمل الصالح
الله عز وجل سمى هذه الاعمال
فقال
والباقيات
الصالحات
سماها باقيات
لانها تبقى
لانها انها لا تزول مع زوال الدنيا
ولا تهلك مع هلاكها
لانها
قد رفعت الى الله
وكل شيء هالك الا وجهه
والذي يعمل
ويكون لوجه الله
فانه لا يزول باقيات صالحات يقول الله
تعالى المال والبنون زينه الحياه الدنيا
هذه زينه الحياه الدنيا يتمتع بها الانسان
ساعه من نهار ثم
يروح ويتركها
كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في حديث
ابن مسعود عند الترمذي
ما لي وللدنيا
انما انا في الدنيا كراكب استظل تحت شجره
ثم راح وتركها
كل شيء هالك الا وجهها الدنيا ملعونه
ملعون ما فيها الا ذكر الله
وما والاه
وعالما ومتعلما
العالم
الذي يعلم عن الله
الذي يحفظ ما انزله الله على عبده
الانبياء لم يورثوا دينارا ولا درهما
وانما ورثوا العلم فمن اخذه اخذ بحظ وافر
اذا مات ابن ادم انقطع عمله الا من ثلاث
صدقه جاريه
اولا ولد صالح يدعو له او علم ينتفع به
فيقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الدنيا
ملعونه بعيده عن الله
الى الزوال ملعون ما فيها ما فيها بعيد عن
الله
اي الى الزوال مضمحل
عاجلا او اجلا
الا ذكر الله
الا عباده الله الا طاعه الله وما والاه
وما كان لله سبحانه
وعالما
ومتعلما
الذي يعلم عن الله والذي يسلك طريق العلم
يطلبه
وان الملائكه لتضع اجنحتها
لط طالب العلم رضا بما يطلب يقول النبي
صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم العلماء ورثه الانبياء
ويقول صلى الله عليه وسلم فضل العالم على
العابد كفضل القمر على سائر الكواكب
ويقول في لفظ ظ فضل العالم على العابد
كفضلي على ادناكم
وان الله
وملائكته
واهل السماوات
والارض
وحتى الحوت في الماء والنمل في جحرها
ليصلون على
معلمي الناس الخير
الله سبحانه وتالى
tells us in a very comprehensive
three verses.
I think it is three verses that 99% of
us all have committed to memory.
‏are
very
expive
us والعصر
ان الانسان لفي خسر
الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وتواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
‏I swear by time itself
that the human being is in a perpetual
state of loss
except for those who believe
and work rightous deeds
and and propagate the truth and propate
and are patience.
رحمه الله تعالى يقول
عن هذه الايات الثلاث لو ما انزل الله حجه
على عباده الا هذه السوره لكفتهم
حجه دامغه
الانسان
في خسر
وانظر الى جميع العصور
والعصر ان الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين
امنوا
الشافعي
اللهصب
[Silence]
‏are
soehensive
and they are
theying
and
are me to awaken
something with us when we to for
the companion رضي الله عنهم
would
[Silence]
each other two or more
they wouldact
whatever it
والعصر ان الانسان لفي خسر الا الذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات وتواصوا بالحق
وتواصوا بالصبر
‏other constantly of the mission
of the goal why are we here this is so
sticky
a person begin to forg
and it's not that it is impermorically
har
unlawful for a person to indulge in this
الله سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
neutal
حمes
constantly
a very glittering and neon
constant seduction
that makes us forget
‏because
j of our
strong and
because
naturally a person
‏Whoever is subjected to it will start
to forget.
‏So we are command to andind ourselves
andind each other
but we are to only this through the lens
of
we have to
mak this ar say I swear by time itself
all of time from the begin of hisory
‏whenever in the future these verses
ring true there's never a time when
these verses are not correct
are not a correct reflection
of what is referred to as the human
experience in this earth
he say I swear by all of time by time
itself
that the human being is in a state of
loss
‏is of
is this the same as the sin
by
people of the b before us thisunding
that human being isor with sin no the
being is pure and innocent
‏All of this
allical
it is in a constant strain toward decay
that's how it was created that's how
that's why we have to work so
‏in con
and
any bind himself to
any of bind himself to inevitable
and so the human being no matter
‏aes no matter how build are no matter
how deep his found
no matter how wealthy and no matter how
far his reach he will have his day in
the sun and then he will
towards that decay he's by it look at
‏here
200 years ag other people own this
and theyed here took pride and they took
care of it and they would kill you and i
for this ground where are they today
we don't even know their names and here
we stand proud and call their ours this
is
‏And so will generation
no matter what you do you cann keep this
from the iss
the human being no matter how tild they
willentually go back into the ground no
matter how deep his foundations they
will they will naturallyentually
go back back back into the
‏and
that there kings on there men and women
who owned and wielded power and known
every and where are they today in the
ground go to the cemetery go to the
graveyard and look around at those grav
stones
‏have
those people
under the in
they dreams you and have they had the
same ambitions they had the same big
plan they were important they were
special they they broke the mold
‏and
the
on top of the ground above them and
their names
and this is our tomorrow
and it's so ironic that the human
‏Allah
is
one the
kind of creature that will birth his own
success
our most beloved our own children they
here to take our place
that's so ironic about this
we love ‏and raise and cle and rear our
children so they are strong enough to
take our place
we will scoot and they take it we raise
our own replacements
because we were never meant to be here
forever we were here for a very
particular thing very particular reason
and no matter how hard you try and
strain ‏to immortalize your name or your
effects on this world it willentually go
back into the box and be recycled again.
That's how it works.
And so Allah swears by all of time that
the human being is in perpetual loss
except
there is a light at the end of the
tunnel. ‏If you have this far, it may
come across as bleak as depressing, as
hopeless. No, the Quran is a book of
hope. That's essentially what it is.
Humanity was in a state of
in a state of darkness and helessness.
الله قران
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلمر
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏people
here they thought this was
how deessing if this is it
makes so manyes
this makes so many promes to us and it
ne has the ability nor the auority toulf
those promes
‏If this was all
deessing
how could youoll your out of
go and take anotherران
الذين امنوا
say by all time beingetcept
‏those
work rightous deeds
propagate the truth and are patient upon
that propagate patience for
anything you do
has to go through these four stages
if you want anything you do or
الايمان
العمل الصالح
التواصي بالحق
التواصي بالصبر
‏ander
trait are any
are that we have
this is how look at
look عليه
you know their last name you know their
father name beforeal media and go to any
‏thousand years ag
years
knows them even those
exas
of time bir
what their name they notalthy
‏How people
them because
their name and prom to them
being perpet
except for those who believe work
rightous deeds propagate the truth and
are steadfast upon pat and these men
have
اقول ما تسمعون واستغفر الله لي ولكم
ولسائر المسلمين فاستغفروه انه هو الغفور
الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والعاقبه للمتقين
ولا عدوان الا على الظالمين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
هو يتولى الصالحين
تاكيدا بعد تاكيد لبيان مقام التوحيد
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله وصفيه من خلقه
وخليله وامينه على وحيه الداعي الى رضوانه
الذي جاهد في الله حق الجهاد حتى اتاه
اليقين اشهد انه رسول الله وعبد الله
صل على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما صليت على
ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم انك حميد مجيد
اللهم بارك على محمد وعلى ال محمد كما
باركت على ابراهيم وعلى ال ابراهيم
في العالمين انك حميد مجيد اللهم انصر
الاسلام والمسلمين واخذل الشرك والمشركين
وافضح النفاق والمنافقين
اللهم اننا نسالك فعل الخيرات وترك
المنكرات وحب المساكين وان تغفر لنا
وترحمنا وتتوب علينا واذا اردت بعبادك
فتنه فاقبضنا اليك غير مفتونين
اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه في
غزه وفلسطين وفي لبنان وفي سوريا وفي
اليمن وحيث حلوا يا رب العالمين اللهم
انصر اخواننا المجاهدين المضطه اللهم
انصرهم حيث كانوا في السودان وفي كشمير
وفي كل مكان اللهم عليك بعدوك وعدوهم فانه
انهم لا يعجزونك اللهم عليك بهذا الكيان
الصهيون اللعين اللهم دمره تدميرا اللهم
صدع بنيانه اللهم زلزل اركانه
اقتل اجناده اللهم انتقم من اهله اللهم
اقذف في قلوبهم الرعب والهلع والفزع يا رب
العالمين اللهم من اراد بهذه الامه سوءا
او مكرا فاجعل تدبيره تدميره يا رب
العالمين ورد كيده في نحره اللهم اننا
نجعلك في نحورهم ونعوذ بك من شرورهم اللهم
اجعل قتلاهم في النيران واجعل شهدائنا في
الجنان اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله
اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على الصلاه
حي على الفلاح
قد قالت الصلاه
قد قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا
اله الا الله
استووا واعتدلوا
حاذوا بين المناكب وسدوا الفرج
المنكب بالمنكب والقدم بالقدم والكعب
بالكعب يستوي الصف ان تسويه الصف واقامه
الصف ‏Pleas
are
you come all the way out here you time
youic time hereay
not
too
by something not being straight in
our not having our coherent
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك وتبارك
الله
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الهاكم التكاثر
الهاكم التكاثر حتى زرتم المقابر
كلا سوف تعلمون ثم كلا سوف تعلمون
كلا لو تعلمون علم اليقين
لترون
الجحيم
ثم لترونها
عين اليقين
ثم لتسالن
يومئذ عن النعيم
الله
سمع الله
لمن حمده
كثيرا مبارك فيه من السماوات ومن الارض
ومنما
ومن
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والعصر
ان
الانسان
لفي خسر
والعصر ان الانسان
لفي خسر الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وت تواصوا بالحق وتواصوا
بالصبر
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استغفر الله استغفر
quick
for our
‏asyفه
شفاء تاما لا يغادر سقما اللهم اجره في
مصيبته واخلف له خيرا منها اللهم افرغ
عليه وعلى اهله الصبر والسلوان
اللهم ربنا اجعل هذه حقبه تكفر لها سيئاته
وترفع في درجاته اللهم عجل في شفائه اللهم
عجل في شفائه اللهم عجل في شفائه اللهم
انت الشافي لا شفاء الا شفاؤك فاشفه يا رب
العالمين اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على
نبينا
আসসালামু আলাইকুম বসার cleம
as you know আলহামদুলিল্লাহ our community
very vibrant
and it has achev the
we also profess that we are not perfect
so we always look for your input back to
us what we can do to improve our
performance
so you have any sugg or com pleas ‏one
of your bo
and let us know unhindered input is
needed from anybody whoever want to give
us the input and improve our activ at
this cই
do what we can and again the bo me i
would you to at least talk to
brother
brother or my and do what we can
to answer or resp to your need or
question any improvement
ট প
আহদ জাব
কশ
পদ আহমদ জাব
প্লাসালামু
আলাইকুম ওরাহমাতুল্লাহি ওয়াবারাকাতুহ
السلام